firstly me do you think mistakes have
been made no I think I'm going to come
back to this report honestly I would
advise caution on this news story
because first of all we've got to get
this into context the reality about this
was that the world did not realize the
extent of the pandemic in China because
it is quite clear now that China
suppressed and hid information for
whatever reasons we may yet discover and
that the World Health Organization which
has serious questions to answer did not
tell the rest of the world that this was
a pandemic that was more than likely to
intrude health organization didn't
inform the world about the threats
that's not true is it they talkin
January sir is that why is that wrong no
that is wrong the reality is that the
World Health Organization did not
interrogate China as they should have
done about the release of the data and
most countries in the West were certain
that this was under control in China it
turns out that it was not that is the
biggest problem the second bit about
this which is quite critical is that
right now every single country in the
world is looking for exactly the same
equipment PPE equipment is exactly the
point every other country is much in the
same boat there's not as though the UK
is suddenly isolated in this every other
country is having to cope with what is
an unprecedented pandemic and the point
I'm trying to make were you're
interrupting me was that this is a
process so the government is trying
desperately to get on top of and has
been since the beginning there are
questions yes that will be asked but
later on not now you have no idea who's
leaking this information whether they're
disgruntled or not we don't know but the
reality is questions will be asked but
is right to ask them once we've
completed this process
got on top of this and then managed to
get the country back up and running
which is absolutely fine okay it is also
rights and fair to ask there whether a
global emergency was declared weeks ago
sorry I didn't answer one question
it is rights and fair for me to ask
whether a global emergency was declared
weeks ago by the World Health
Organization it's quite right for you to
ask questions but the question here is
really important is the government doing
the right thing is it trying desperately
quite rightly to obtain PPE equipment is
it trying to support our frontline staff
yes the answer those questions are yes
but is every other country doing exactly
the same yes that is the problem this
pandemic is on unprecedented scale and
every country is in exactly the same
place trying to get the same equipment
from the same suppliers this is the key
problem in Italy in Spain in France
Germany and in America every country is
in the same boat so what I'm asking is
we get a bit of context on this and
understand that the information about
this should have been out much earlier
much earlier than just the end of
January should have been out in December
when the real data was known that this
was a serious problem and was spreading
but if by late February scientists were
warning policymakers that of the UK
conserve the 380 thousand deaths without
urgent intervention is fair to ask
whether the government's could have
addressed this more aggressively and
also whether the government should have
been sending PPE to China again let's
put this in context the government it
was all the advice that was given to
them by the medical professionals and by
the scientists they have followed
exactly to the letter that is critical
now the whole point about this PPE point
get there again in context at the time
we were understanding that China was
getting under control on this issue and
therefore support from many other
countries not just the UK to try and
help China contain this we did not know
at the time that the data on this was
far more extensive and should have been
released but however that was trying to
contain it in China not let it spread it
turns out because people were still
moving out of China that that had
already began to spread
that was known this government other
governments in France and all these
other countries they then had to take
the advice of the scientists in how to
control it and I think the government
did do exactly what they were asked we
will learn later on exactly what was
said to them and what they did burn on
my belief is from talking to ministers
they followed the scientific and medical
advice from start to finish and now we
must plan for a moment when we can start
moving out and get the economy so that
it is working again otherwise the damage
will be enormous okay as I said in my
introduction you were once the leader
the Conservative Party if you had once
upon a time been the prime minister
would you have missed five Cobra
meetings after the alarm bells had been
raised well Cobra is a set of letters
standing for Cabinet Office briefing
room a Cobra meetings take place all the
time most of them are functional and
planning meetings when I was in cabinet
the Prime Minister did not attend every
single planning to attend the cobra
meeting in the grips of a global
emergency I would expect him to have
delegated to those relevant secretaries
of state to run those areas that were
meeting in the Cobra room the key point
here is the Prime Minister attends when
it needs all of those departments to be
pulled together for a particular
function I believe he did that the key
element is each of the secretaries of
state working together is responsible
one of them normally takes a lead at a
meeting like that when it's planning so
that's a health lead then they will have
all the other relevant sections of state
around the table and they will take the
lead on it the Prime Minister comes in
when it requires an executive decision
about something which has up till then
not being decided so it is normal for a
prime minister not to be at Cobra
meetings only when his presence is
absolutely vital because that's what you
pay secretaries of state for to do their
job and to run their departments and to
coordinate activity ministers to do his
job in all fairness mr. Duncan Smith
with hindsight should events like the
Charlton races which saw 250 people
gather together in one place over the
course of four days should that have
taken place
it depends what the advice was if the
scientific advice and medical advice as
I understand it was and I wasn't there
but as I understand it was that it was
okay to continue with those those events
at that time so that is the critical
issue did the government listen to the
advice I believe they did but we will
know later on whether that was the case
or not but I believe they did listen to
that advice and that advice was they
were okay to go ahead at the time now we
may inhale mine site say all the figures
that that were around maybe that
shouldn't have been the case but the
question for government which you keep
asking is what advice did the government
follow and the government has made it
clear they followed scientific and metal
advice from their scientific advisors
and their medical advisors and I think
that's the critical question once the
dust is finally settled and we are
through this pandemic would you welcome
an inquiry to investigate them what went
wrong there will always be an inquiry to
figure out what went right and what went
wrong and that will happen my point here
today is to try and undertake that now
on the backs of leaks and suggestions
from others we don't know who they are
would be a mistake what we need to
recognize is the lockdown is working we
need to make sure that happens we need
to help and support the government in
trying to get as much PPE equipment in
as other countries are trying to do at
the same time and to get through this so
that we can as I have set out plan to
get the economy moving in a three-phase
process once we've got this under
control that's the critical bit we
should be talking to the public saying
there is a way out of this here is how
it is and let's trust them to understand
the difference between a lockdown
measure and the fact that at some point
will be coming out that's the critical
question and the also the critical
question is that we don't know exactly
how long it is before the restrictions
are going to be completed lifted but the
key question for us is at what point do
we think it's going to be okay to be
able to start moving the economy back
out and I think if you look at the other
countries that are doing it they're
doing it at about the level of half peak
of those who are arriving in hospitals
etc that may be a target figure but the
government will have to figure that out
and the medical advice but the key bit
is let's say
what the plan will be so the public
businesses and others can start to plan
when we move out they'll know how it'll
be done